prends parler nous sommes en direct avec
arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef revue
politique et parlementaire bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous comment réagir à
cette prise de parole de marion
maréchal-le pen qui est pourtant nous
avait habitués à beaucoup de discrétion
ces dernières années oui alors ça
s'inscrit dans un contexte très
particulier où on voit bien que la
question autour des relations entre
communautés
re devient leur jeu politique juste au
demeurant après le des confidences qui
montrent quelque part que le monde
d'avant reste très persistant dans le
fameux monde d'après pour ce qui
concerne marion maréchal le battre ce
n'est pas une nouveauté elle s'est déjà
exprimé à plusieurs reprises sur
différents sujets
là une stratégie de communication qui
vise de manière pointilliste à ne pas se
faire oublier dans le débat public
elle est en réserve du rassemblement
national depuis sa décision de ne pas se
représenter aux élections législatives
en 2017
mais elle veut incarner d'or la galaxie
de la droite de la droite
une parole qui est une parole libre
libre de l'appareil politique du
rassemblement national parce que à
plusieurs reprises elle a fait entendre
sa différence et une sensibilité
spécifique par rapport à marine le pen
et elle souhaite vraisemblablement elle
l'a d'ailleurs dit à plusieurs reprises
être une forme de 2,2 d'offres
d'agrégation de toute une droite qui ne
se retrouverait pas dans les appareils
politiques classiques donc cette
stratégie de communication est une
stratégie qui est assez passé depuis
encore une fois sa décision se mettre en
retrait de la vie politique et ce
qu'elle vient de nous dire aujourd'hui
finalement est tout à fait j'allais dire
cohérent avec en tout cas son sa
disposition à communiquer depuis depuis
sa leleu sa prise de distance avec la
vie politique
justement on va on va l'écouter and
obesity marion maréchal qui s'exprime
moi je refuserai de mettre un genou à
terre comme le souhaiterait
manifestement le ministre de l'intérieur
et il aura suffi d'une manifestation de
20000 personnes devant le palais de la
justice
je rappelle quand même que les gilet
jaune c'était deux cent cinquante mille
personnes au plus fort de la
mobilisation pour que soudainement
le gouvernement cède à toutes les
injonctions je considère que je n'ai pas
à m'excuser en tant que blanche et en
tant que française voyez à quoi on en
est réduit en devant se positionner de
la sorte je n'ai pas à m'excuser pour la
mort d'un afro américain des états unis
je n'ai pas à m'excuser pour la mort
d'un délinquant adama traoré une mort
accidentelle qui a eu lieu à la suite
d'une interpellation qui n'étaient pas
liés c'est important de le rappeler à sa
couleur de peau mais au crime qu'il
aurait commis lui d'ailleurs et une
partie de sa famille manifestement les
mots sont forts quand même arnaud
benedetti d'ailleurs il s'apparente un
peu à ceux du conseiller régional et
rennes julien odoul qui s'était fait
justement réprimée 1 par marine le pen
marine le pen justement qui a dit que
voilà ça ne serait peut-être tomber dans
dans un double piège c'est une rupture
une nouvelle rupture entre les deux
femmes
alors je ne suis pas sûr que ça soit une
rupture c'est l'expression en tout cas
d'une sensibilité qui est différente
il est évident que marine le pen
maintenant depuis un certain nombre
d'années même on peut le dire à une
volonté de rendre acceptables l'image du
de l'ex front national devenu
rassemblement national avec marion
maréchal on l'a toujours eue à son même
quand elle était députée une expression
politique était un peu différente de
celle de sa tante souvenez-vous à
l'époque des manifestations contre le
mariage pour tous elle n'hésitez pas à
elles à prendre position contre le
mariage pour tous alors que sa tante ne
participait pas aux défis des dons
qu'elle a toujours exprimé une ligne
beaucoup plus droitière à l'intérieur du
rassemblement social et d'une certaine
manière elle reprend la stratégie qui
était celle de jean marie le pen c'est à
dire que dans un débat où on voit bien
d'ailleurs que la question de la
racialisation et ça c'est nouveau je
pense quand même parce que la question
de l'arrêt salle la racialisation du
débat politique
pour la première fois elle n'est pas
forcément partie portées par la droite
de la droite voire par l'extrême droite
elle est portée par des formations
d'extrême gauche qui expriment des
revendications communautaires
donc elle y répond avec disons le corpus
politique qui est le sien et elle adopte
en fin de compte la stratégie qui était
celle de son grand père c'est à dire
elle veut exprimer tout haut ce qu'une
partie de l'opinion publique pense
vraisemblablement tout bas quant au
contexte dans lequel nous nous
retrouvons et ne voir là aucune ambition
comme elle l'avait d'ailleurs dit
elle-même début octobre à la candidature
à la présidentielle en 2022 vous savez
il ya deux hypothèses en fait de lire la
relation entre marine le pen et marion
maréchal-le pen
la première hypothèse c'est de
considérer que elle serait d'une
certaine manière opposée est en
concurrence pour prendre le leadership
de
la droite populiste nationale
souverainiste peu importe comment comme
on l'appelle ça c'est une première
lecture
il ya une deuxième lecture qui consiste
aussi à imaginer que finalement les deux
femmes se partagent une tâche commune
c'est à dire que l'objectif de 2 de
marine le pen est temps de recentrer de
dédiaboliser toujours plus l'image du
duduk de l'ancien front national dont on
a d'ailleurs changé le nom pour faire
oublier les antécédents du front
national avec un discours qui serait un
discours souverainiste social
républicain d'ailleurs marine le pen
vient de publier une tribune dans notre
revue la revue politique ou
parlementaire où contrairement à son
père
l annonce de manière très claire qu'elle
s'inscrit en tout cas dans une dans une
filiation gaulliste ce que d'aucuns lui
contexte lui conteste et puis même
marion maréchal-le pen serait finalement
aux avant-postes pour draguer un
électorat plus droitiers plus
identitaire voire parfois plus
catholique ce qui permettrait ensuite la
fusion de ces deux de ces deux blocs
dans une dynamique électorale
il ya aussi cette hypothèse qui ne faut
pas totalement écartée on peut penser
quand même que à ce stade compte tenu du
fait que marine le pen tient l'appareil
du rassemblement national que elle
parvient à pour l'instant réussir une
implantation qui est certes encore
contenue mais sur le plan local qu'elle
reste la candidate la plus disons
crédible pour représenter cette famille
politique
même si indéniablement aujourd'hui dans
une partie de cette droite là marion
maréchal-le pen exercent une forte une
forte attractivité pour un électorat qui
est certainement plus identitaire merci
à nos benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire merci
d'avoir été avec nous